thanks for coming everyone so my name is
Luis bollo I work at volunteer and guys
about model compression and sure you can
go to the next slide
cool so here is sort of like a cur
recurring a story that happens if you
want to keep lace or like simple models
so chapter one is that you have some
data and after you clean it and
feature-wise if you go and someone tells
you go build a model Thanks and then you
go and you build a simple model that it
has let's say and I use your point six
besides and then you tool the hell out
of this and then you put all kinds of
tricks and then you get an A you see of
0.7 next yeah and then your boss turns
you and it says okay I did not hire you
to build this [ __ ] models next and then
you go oh but if I build a more complex
model then it's going to be really hard
to maintain it because the users might
not be as technical and it's hard to
debug and it's hard to interpret and
there's like all kinds of problems but
still it's problematic next and your
boss turns to you and says okay nice
pairs of glasses you have there it would
be a real shame if something happened to
them and chapter 8 is you go and you
find it appeals a more complex model and
after doing all kinds of things you
might get in a you see of 0.8 and the
issue is that like forever you're going
to live with this complicated model
which is hard to interpret them are to
debug and there's all kinds of issues
and the whole point that I want to show
here is that like this implication does
not have to hold so just because you
tried a simple model and you guys like
chitti a metrics and then you try the
complicated one and you got good metrics
it does not mean that you need to leave
with a complicated model forever
next go one more and so yeah so that's
the comb on the concept of model
compression is that from a complicated
model it has like really good accuracy
you can somehow like mess it down to
like a simpler model while preserving
like a lot of the accuracy that it has
and why would you do it like it's easier
to maintain it's easier to debug when
you have problems with your data it's
faster
requires less memory and energy if
you're using it like in mobile or in
like cars or something like that and
very importantly also it's easier to
interpret it just makes it like much
easier for everything yeah and so yeah
this concept like shows like for example
like in this paper if you guys want to
read more and as well and some others
but that's a good starting point so I'll
show you guys like a best example of how
this can work so the first thing is we
do there is that we have your training
set and you build the decision tree to
to like that model and you get in in a
you see of 0.77 and then you go and you
build a random forest and after tuning
and doing all kinds of things you can
get in AU 0.85 and now you you are data
stage that you think you might be stuck
with the random forest forever and like
you're never going to be able to
visualize the thing properly and so on
and next yeah so the following like
trick is an example of like the model
compression is that you can train
decision tree using the labels as
predicted by the random forests so as
you guys can see here instead of using a
white rain for example you can use the
predictions of the random forest as the
labels for that so you're pretty much
ignoring the real labels and you're just
using the labels at the predictions of
the more complicated model and very
often the claim is is that this really
boosts the performance and like it's
enough there's this gap of like a day
you see points and it's depending on the
on your particular needs these like
three year you see points might be fine
for you to live with and you might
prefer to use a decision tree for
example and the intuition behind this is
that like obviously like real data has
all kinds of issues with it has outliers
it has mistakes it has all kinds of
things and when you train these like
more complex model and you only use
those predictions it's kind of like
smooth south like the
surface that you're trying to train on
and in that sense it makes it like
easier for like a simpler model to
defeat that data and go so that's the
sort of like the most basic example of
how to do this and there is like all
kinds of other tricks that you can do
one and this is always very hard I would
say hierarchically train incrementally
less complex models and so by that I
mean like you can try like random
forests with like with like stronger and
stronger regularization parameters or
like less trees until you like sir if I
go down to a two decision tree for
example if you have a lot of unlabeled
data for example you can use your
complex model to label that data and you
can basically have like as much as you
as much unlabeled data you have and then
train your simple model with this like
huge previously unlabeled data set and
that well as well and the third part
which is really like well explained in
the in that paper is that you can also
like statically generate data so for
that like I'll defer the details to the
paper but but you basically create a lot
of fake data and then label it with with
the complex model and then train the
simpler one based on that cool so this
summer is the following that you have
model compression is useful in making
complex models into simpler ones which
can make like life much easier and just
to clarify this doesn't apply only to
random forests and decision trees it's
like a general sort of like patterns and
it's pretty easy to do like in it's
simpler stages you just have to train
the example model with the lace labels
coming from the more complex one and as
we mention like if you have a lot of
unlabeled data or if you don't have any
more data to train on you can
synthetically generate data as described
in that paper and
yeah and analogous concepts that we
didn't talk about exist for like for
deep learning models as well but the
idea there is a little bit different and
says it's mostly about like reducing
like the space required by the model for
like energy consumption for example and
yeah that's all I have I think that time
for one question only yeah so there's a
few different ways like is that you can
just look at the at the marginal
distribution of each of the features and
then like generate each row where each
column is like independently generator
chords at marginal distribution so
that's like the Bayes example and I in
the paper to describe one ways to to
approximate the Joint Distribution and
generate like something which is not
independent but that's the basic idea
essentially it's a good question so I
use the regressor because I trained on
the predicted probabilities so the
labels were like numbers between zero
and ones rather than just like zero one
cool I always take more questions like
during the break if you guys ever go for
the next speaker I'm going to talk about
my research on that distributing taxes
across the city south of that kitchen of
what they're via does what we're
building what you think is their future
operating system for transportation this
is a shared on-demand service can you go
to the next slide please so that's a
screenshot of our dashboard each scene
is a is a taxi and they're going across
the city being up and dropping down
passengers you've got next one
each blue person is a is the origin of a
booking and orange person is
assassination in order to avoid detour
for passengers already on board we ask
riders to go to a nearby street corner
I've indicated by the small line
this allows a very very large sharing
aggregating multiple right into the same
vehicle which is both ecological and
allows us to offer a short extra level
prices with a special sexy feeling to
their selves can you go to the next
slide here's an example of our online
algorithm that matches right that are
similar that have similar effect into
the same vehicle in my talk I am NOT
going to talk about this matching
algorithm it deserves its own talk I'm
going talk about as another problem we
have how to instruct our drivers to
start the work day when each driver
starts walking we send them a path to a
specific location to be at why is this
two reasons one we want drivers to be
close to well F there will be bookings
we like our customers to have preeminent
wait time for a taxi or other than the
let's say 11 minutes everyone who knows
it like if you're using a taxi and so on
and another thing is we don't want to
pay drivers too much for the dead time
whether it is when the adult can go on
the way to the first customer right the
what we usually do for this is a look at
where their bookings are early in the
morning and produce some kind of heat
map across the city this is a data from
that taxi Authority in Singapore we have
similar data for real service and we
have an algorithm that matches taxes
according to this information I'm going
to talk about when what we do in this
approach doesn't work why my did not
work when we're spreading into new city
next slide if there are unique
challenges that are related
to the small scale of the service
there's a small smaller number of early
adaptors and you want to give them very
good service so that we'll have good
word of mouth and we'll grow up but we
don't want to spend a lot of money
paying drivers to drive taxi to be able
to pick this definition of f inches up
it's possible to use a few vehicles of
course there's only a few bookings
initially and it's hard to use
statistical methods because noise
overwhelmed the signal when the numbers
are small and the big issue is that we
can spread our vehicle supply as thinly
as we like if one neighborhood has
demand justifying half half a taxi and
another neighborhood at the map
justifying another half a tactic we have
to pick one okay so I get into the
detail of the big heads of the problem
for a new city and Devon so we like our
drivers to cover as large an area as
possible but we can't tell them to stop
just anywhere for example it will be
very useful to have a driver on Ayalon
because they can cover they can get very
quickly to a large area from there but
we can't tell them to wait there for
further live so our local team mark
places that are safe and legal stop
across the city which we and we send all
these those latest for a driver's window
starting the shift we have an no number
of vehicles which are available for
service once all services behind for a
few days we have information where
demand is and we run we can run the
shareability algorithm and see which
lies will be shared when their one
we'll fix them and without what we want
to produce is how many taxis to send to
each location out of the list of
locations in order to minimize total
passenger wear time this is equivalent
to measuring the average wait time
because only the first dissector and
it's not and well the the goal function
won't have a driver dead time at all
because since we save our drivers time
anyway
the only cost to us of the driver
parking and waiting for the first line
is there is opportunity because of the
better service Nichols offered if they'd
been elsewhere at the time so how do we
formulate this mathematically exercise
we define these variables the X
variables or the outputs that we want
how many texts send to each location
across the city and well okay link leave
it at that for a minute
and the Y variables or or indicator
viable indicate the entire scenario of
which ride would be would have been
picked up in the English scenario we're
looking for and we're going to optimize
over both x and y at the same time for
each ride the multiple Y variable almost
all of them are zero and one of them is
one indicating them where we send a taxi
for this specific rider and this binary
information encodes the entire service
early in the morning and our goal is to
minimize the total weight I mean that
would have been in this scenario this
expression is the sum of our locations
and drive most of the terms in the sum
of because almost all the Yser 0 for
each ride will be one of these letters
will be one which indicates which then
would have picked
this rider and we just inserted in a
miracle content of how long it would
take and to drive from this stop
location to the riders booking point
this allows - this is a very simple
expression because it's just a linear
expression in the variables we have
similar constraints on the problem click
this which are similar form in the order
of linear form the total number of taxis
we allocated to all of the location is
the total suicide every ride itself
every booking should be served and as
the number of taxis we send out of each
side - supplication can't be more than
we sent there initially in the morning
so this class of optimization problem
where all the well the target function
as well as all the constraints of linear
functions of the problem variables is
called a linear program you may remember
this from the OCS classes can you go to
the next lesson
these problems are easy to solve when
the variables or a allowed to control
grid numbers all to the right
continuously however once you have
discrete for those integers or will or
bool and now face becoming a becoming
spinelli harder sort of takes time that
is essentially exponentially in there
the number of discrete values and
doesn't depend on the number of
continuous available in our case the X's
we have a few dozens of them all
integers and the Y's we have a few
thousand of them because it's a tensor
product applications and bookings do
binary this is thousands of integer
bubbles which is totally impractical to
solve however we found out so we what do
we do we poured over algorithm step
algorithm text books and papers and
found out a neat trick once the X
variables all set to concrete values the
problem of optimizing for just the Y
variables have a special form it's
called a totally unique modular a linear
organ
this kind of linear program have the
property that just solution even if the
valve is that allowed to vary
continuously the solution will always be
in integers I won't get into what this
technical condition is it's from the
coefficients in the problem in our case
it allows us to say that the X variables
must be integers and then a the Y
variables can relax the condition and
allow them to vary continuously and have
whatever value they want between 0 and 1
and but we're guaranteed by total
hilarity of the partial problem that the
optimal solution will have all Y valves
is a 0 or Y in the best solution so you
so if we set the in fixing value values
to be integer and Y values to be
continuous this will be a department
will be tractable it's all perfectly
within second because we have only a
dozen of X levels corresponding to safe
locations in the city the the solution
will be the same as before Y's will be
the optimal values for Y will be boolean
numbers so this is made us pretty happy
and another thing we can do now is that
new is that we can vary the constraint
on the total number of X's and see what
marginal gains get from adding another
taxi to the service and see if it's
worth the cost or not so a word about
how we did this research we use them and
you don't max like use the Python
library pulp it's a library for linear
programming and it's very healthy very
straightforward the interface you just
go here we set the XS to variables that
are integers and Y to general variables
and we give the objective in almost
exactly the same form as close as
possible to mathematical notation within
tighten which made it very easy to
experiment and tweak our approach
and and find out a solution basically we
work eventually find the best possible
distribution we can so that's if it any
question like you have this formulation
like you know we're saying they're the
most right away you know let actually
are you not all right so what do i
benefit from using this library and the
I you need a strong solver solving the
problem with a dozen integer variables
is not something you can program by
yourself you need to use an optimization
librarian they're usually written either
in fortune or if you're lucky in C++
clip a slash and you need to wrap them
in Python and or a construct text files
with inputs the tail parse and the run
for you which is very unwieldy it's a
delivery because because it's so easy to
use and uses strong solvers in the
backend made it very easy to experiment
from different era presentations of the
problem until we found this one that has
the possibility to run check
yeah ok thanks everyone
[Applause]
so Jam but if there is a project that I
did with y'all gross who is over here
and the your CID who is not and who's
there turning the slide ok so what
what's Jam but essentially it's a it's a
program that they should L pay unskilled
me inspiring musicians that have no idea
how to play to be able to play a music
where we wanted to create such a program
that helped them but since Nano may be
exactly have any formal musical
education we didn't want the program to
have any either so in order to do that
we wanted there to the program to to be
able to listen to music and to
understand what's important and for this
we need some kind of supervised their
data so a there's actually a lot of
other programs that they generate music
and all this but they usually use boring
public domain we do data set that it's
like very old songs and it's not very
fun so we use the program called Guitar
Pro Guitar Pro is a it's the program
from sometimes around 2005 that is
mainly used for kids to learn to play
guitar and it contains a lot of rock pop
songs that we can use and in order to to
to do them to demonstrate their to the
program what it's like to play with the
unskilled musician with Reedus basis as
unskilled musicians obviously so we're
we created about a bunch of a guitar and
bass spares and trying to - to learn how
ow
the guitarist responds to the playing of
the best so this is what the guitar
profiles look like you can see there's a
bunch of tracks lead guitar rhythm
guitar bass and percussion and for for
each time stamps you can you can see
what's there the guitar the instrument
did at the time stamp so this is the
guitar strings and this is when you play
the first fret on the E then the rest
not nothing on the a string and so on so
we couldn't use
such a thing we wanted to use a smaller
a smaller domain because we didn't want
to to learn the entire scale of the
guitar so we limited the bulk the best
bass and the guitar to a single octave
and we used viel tags to model the
whether a string is put a note is played
or not so and we had a lot of a lot of a
lot of problems representing the time
and we ended up just using absolute
timing and next slide so this is an
example of what the data it looks like
this is apparently should represent the
best and the guitar of say a shade of
winter by simon and garfunkel
you can see a for each times times times
we have twelve twelve notes and B means
we pressed on a note and I pray a means
we didn't release the note a so you can
see the guitar a kind of kind of plays
more notes than the base for each note
of the bass there's roughly two notes
from the guitar as you can see like this
is a single note and this is two notes
from the guitar so and okay so ever had
a demo of what a first song sounds like
because it's kind of mess it's kind of
messes things up so this is like the
ideal output of the system
[Music]
okay so and we wanted to learn from it
so and the model we use is kind of a
standard LCI model where we treated each
each each 12 characters what we seen as
a board they did to 12 dimensions actors
physical and lsdm and then try to
predict the guitar a part for the for
their for their and for this way a
timestamp and in order to do real time
planing play I think we connected a MIDI
keyboard first it to the 12 character
format use the model for prediction
turned it back to MIDI and then send it
to logic M Oh next slide so we have a
bunch of demos first where we feel they
say they're the best the best of a
little Iqbal from the Ramones and this
is what came out
[Music]
it's just a bad okay and so this is the
output affair and the other example is
actually me playing with it
so where am I
manually added an effect for for my
flanks so it we could be distinguished
from the gem but playing so it's kind of
sounds kind of funny that's it and and
so there's a lot a lot of future work
that we need to do because they
currently there is no normal way to
evaluate this distinct and there's a lot
of metadata we didn't use and we
expected a lot of the things from there
from the model for example a we didn't
specify a jean or when it rained it so
we just learned all the Jenners it
doesn't distinguish between bass guitar
and rhythm guitars which is a totally
different rules when they play so that's
why it's kind of a mess and and that's
about it
thank you hello i'm monica sue I'm from
Intuit and the data science is there I'm
actually from our California office but
I'm here working with our Israeli team
as well and I'm going to tell you a
story today about one of the problems
that we're working on called battling
adaptive adversaries it's a story about
fraud detection and prevention within
one of our products which is called
TurboTax and so I'll start by giving
some context about turbo and the reason
for that is so that you can understand
the
a fraud we're detecting and also because
the problem that this product is trying
to solve is somewhat specific to the
United States and Canada so you might be
aware that in the United States
virtually everyone has to file manually
and equal tax returns and there's an
actually deadline it's usually April
15th where everyone has to do this and
it's quite a painful process because
also be aware the United States tax code
is quite complex so if you were to do
this manual yourself you would be
selling out many many forms across hours
and perhaps days and the last point
which is also really important context
is that around 77% of filers receive a
refund check so money back from the
government after filing their taxes and
that's because as you're paying your
income tax throughout the year you can
overpay and ultimately the government
will pay you back the reason that's
important context is because there's
money involved and that's why this is an
attractive area to fraudsters in to the
next and so to it just as a brief
introduction along with what but already
mentioned we have a suite of products
which aims to simplify the the finances
of both consumers and small businesses
and and TurboTax is one of our products
and it's it's serves to simplify this
tax filing process for United States and
Canadian customers so this problem of
fraudsters trying to take advantage of
this tax refund the really the source of
that problem is that there are there's
been a growing number of data loss
incidences with the within the public
and financial sector and so I won't go
through all of these statistics but I
think it will be no surprise to anyone
that there's a growing number of
personally identifying information
that's available to fraudsters who would
like to take advantage of probably a lot
of system
including tax ID theft and the last
point is in two it is not battling tax
ID theft on its own we actually are
working with the IRS the Internal
Revenue Service of the United States
government as well as other industry
players and the state Department of
Revenue's so this is an article that was
published about this problem and the
reason this is an interesting problem
from a data science perspective is that
fraudsters are constantly evolving to
evade our detection strategies so we
have to get we have to build better
models and get better along with them
and we use a multi-faceted approach to
detect fraud and I'm going to tell you
about one of them which is very heavily
data-driven and and I'll go through some
lessons that we've learned along the way
so one of the really important lessons
is that we need to centralize all of the
data across our products in order to get
a really holistic view of fraud in our
system so ultimately we're trying to
distinguish legitimate customers from
fraudsters and you need to collect all
of the data that you possibly can in
order to do that really really well so
this includes application logs such as
the login data from everyone that's
trying to log into TurboTax it includes
clickstream data so tracking all of the
clicks within our products and how
people are interacting with the website
and mobile app user entered data so that
is of course what they're actually
entering in their account as well as the
tax filing itself and we also use some
third-party data so we get signals from
external to Intuit to help solve this
problem really importantly we centralize
all of these data sources in a Hadoop
data Lake and this is what allows us to
build models utilizing all of these data
sources so on top of the data Lake
actually if you can go back on top of
the data Lake we have this actually if
you go back on an analytical layer and
so this is where we build models and
perform analytics to better understand
fraud the suspicious activity in our
system
and then on top of that we also have
importantly have an operational layer
this is where the forensic analysts can
actually comb through the data identify
suspicious activity and do something
about it if some unfortunately something
happens in our systems so so the first
lesson was to centralize all the data
the second lesson is to have a
continuous feedback loop between that
operational layer and the analytical
layer so as I said there's forensic
analysts working in the operational
layer and they're identifying suspicious
activity and they're sending labels to
the data scientists and analysts who
work in this analytical layer this is
the most powerful part of our
infrastructure because we're
continuously injecting human knowledge
and expertise into the models that we
build so labels allow us to of course
build supervised machine learning
algorithms or models but it also allows
us to validate unsupervised machine
learning and then in return we send them
actually go back one in return we we
send them our risk scores that come out
of our models and this is really
important as well because we can seed
their investigations and we can validate
the results that we get in our current
models okay so if we look more closely
in the analytical layer this is a overly
simplified picture of how we build
different components that are reusable
for different datasets and use cases in
our systems so a feature Iser are
building features to use in supervised
machine learning and we do this in two
different ways one is in a continuous
fashion using Scala spark and ML lists
to have continuous data feature ization
for close to real-time feature ization
for predictive modeling we also have a
batch pipeline which uses sequel and
Python in order to have another set of
models but not acting in real-time as
the data comes in to our data Lake the
other components are our
more of a platform so they're reusable
for different datasets and use cases we
train and test models we publish our
signals that are used in our models to
an external key value store and of
course we have metrics and monitoring as
well and the last is to actually not
just detect fraud within that analytical
layer but bring those insights back to
our products so that we can prevent
fraud in real time so again this is an
overly simplified picture but we want to
enable our products to make real time
decisions about how to act on suspicious
activity so we do that by servicing our
models to a model host and at every
login event in TurboTax the product is
able to retrieve a risk score and
therefore move from detection to actual
fraud prevention I want to go through
example of a supervised model with
design so I told you we have a
continuous feature ization as well as a
batch feature ization and in one example
of our batch feature ization we use a
random forest classifier so this is
something you probably are very familiar
with we have a decision tree here and at
each node you're making decisions about
whether something meets a certain
criteria at every node and ultimately
you're deciding whether something is
good it's a good customer versus a
fraudulent actor and random forest is a
collection of decision trees we like it
because they can be trained in parallel
they're fast to train test and validate
and you can get feature importance for
free so you can learn about which
features are actually important for
detecting fraud the reason I mentioning
this is because we've we've I guess had
a challenge of running scikit-learn
where we we build our decision trees
over MapReduce because our our models
are quite complex or they're quite large
and we wanted to parallel live them and
we use a Hadoop streaming API to do this
and so to train the model you can
train each tree with a separate mapper
and ultimately write one file into HDFS
into Hadoop per tree and then in the
reduced stuff you're combining all of
the trees into one model and similarly
there's a separate MapReduce stuff to
ultimately make a prediction and the
last thing I want to mention is that we
heavily utilize Luigi in our pipeline so
this batch pipeline I said is a
combination of sequel and Python
sequel to do the feature ization and
python to do machine learning and the
sequel part is hundreds and hundreds of
sequel scripts and it's a pain to
actually manage all of the tasks that
are required because there's a ton of
dependency on one another so we use a PG
which is a dependency manager for tax
execution and as you probably know it's
written in Python and was built by an
open source PI Spotify it's a really
nice test integer because you basically
create a class for each feature or for
each task that you need to run in your
pipeline you specify the command the the
command that actually that's script and
you can specify which tests need to be
run before that can be run and this has
been super critical for our managing our
hundreds and hundreds of sequel scripts
required for this pipeline so in summary
the lessons that we've learned from
fraud detection that Intuit is to first
centralize all of our data sources and
we do that in the Hadoop data link we
set up a feedback loop between
operations and analytics this gives us
continuous label data and human
intelligence and directed into our
models we perform continuous data
processing for some close to real-time
detection and then we actually move from
detection to prevention by enabling
real-time decisioning and product and
that's it I can take questions yeah just
I was one about the physiology tennis
they took off the feed button
or how these Russians in cases where
cases you can adopt the features and
realize that the moment was working on
them okay yeah that's a great a great
question so we do have a feedback loop
but sometimes those labels get stale
because they're involving so you kind of
can honey
Oh once I he asked how I don't know
exactly the words that you used but
basically as we have this feedback loop
set up between the operations people and
the data scientists how do you make sure
your models are able to evolve to the
latest activities that the processors
are doing that correct well I collect
definitely how we adapt to the some news
out of seven they notice how fitting the
whole doesn't in any way I think how to
be specifically about to company
recognizing that I don't know where
people live X amount of apartments are
more likely to commit set of laws or not
like how to be without suddenly axonal
so so as the fraudsters are changing
some of our labels will get stale and
the newest labels might have these new
patterns like the ones that you just
described and so what we do is build
models that are just based on the most
recent label data in addition to one
that has different look back windows
does that make sense maybe I miss it but
why do you use it like you can note the
family and your possible so we have two
separate
fraud detection pipelines and one uses
Scala spark and ml live but the one that
I was talking about is the more of a
batch pipeline which we're using both
sequel and Python so we do use it okay
thank you very much I'm kind of skipping
the details of what I'll decorate those
weather what is especially in the
programming and just giving to the gist
of five useful decorators hopefully at
least one of them would be useful for
you okay so let's start
so just a second a decorator is the
basically what comes after the edge sign
before a function so you can see a
simple decorator here now one very
useful decorator is called the less
recently used decorator all you have to
do is USB at LRU cache and the number of
the amount of cash you want and your
function can perform better now let's
see how that happens for example I have
this classic example of the Fibonacci
function implemented rather than a blink
as you will expect with an active of n
is the Fibonacci of n minus 1 plus n
minus 2 and I time it so I time it for
with an actually of 30 and it runs for
approximately 440 milliseconds now yes
by using this simple decorator of keep
the left used a entries return values
forever
no maximal size the function runs for
less than one millisecond so 160 626
nanoseconds so let's also change like
typing like 10 characters so you might
say it it okay Fibonacci is kind of a
made-up example give me something that
has something to do with the data
science so those of you who work with
natural language processing are public
familiar with the Levenstein levenshtein
distance 11-time distance is basically
between two words the amount of
insertions and deletions that you have
to make for example assuming that has
the word reshape and they want to
measure the distance to the world shape
I remove the R and the E and add an S at
the end so the levenshtein distance is 3
okay so very simple definition and it's
very very useful for auto correcting
spelling mistakes and search so this is
how you calculate the living time
distance it's a recursive function is
even optimized here it's not clear how
you might make it run faster and now we
run it on real data it for those of you
who aren't familiar with this is a
really cool trick all Linux machines
including a Mac have a dictionary so
what I did here is I randomised ten
words then real world on the dictionary
and this one came out and four
I calculated the 11th time distance of
all possible combinations so then times
10 it's running the function for a
hundred times okay and I measure the
performance of this levenshtein distance
once with the LRU cache demo ization and
once without so let's see the results
okay so look at this
and I have here with the memorization we
transfer approximately 10 milliseconds
and without 40,000 milliseconds I'm not
demonstrating it here because I have
limited time you can see it with a
simple insertion everything runs faster
and I didn't have to implement anything
on my on my own
okay so memorization is nice
memorization is actually cashing in
memory but memory is limited and most of
the time I wanted to cash on my hard
drive so let's see how we can implement
this disk caching with decorators okay
so what you see here is a pretty simple
decorator I came up with for writing the
results in adjacent firm format to disk
now what is the Creator does is
basically it gets a function it stores
its return value if a file with that
name exists it pulls it up to the file
if not it saved it to the file and
return the value the use is pretty easy
let's see for example so what I got here
the calculation of one plus one and I
artificially made it to run for two
seconds and I won't run it now but trust
me that the first time it will run for
two seconds and a second time which
which one immediately now this is nice
but what they actually want is to use
the parameters in some way I don't want
to save the data in cached dot JSON I
want it to be like Fibonacci of n dot
JSON and wants to have the argument in
now this isn't trivial how this can be
done so introducing
the inspection model those of you
unfamiliar with and I'll give a short
intro in Python there are three ways to
call a function and three basic ways
once is to use named parameters for
example this function sums three numbers
and have a third on the third argument
optional very simple gets a B and C and
sum them the second option is to get
positional arguments and use this style
arcs again the same functionality
different signature and the third way we
field named arguments using a key value
dictionary again with the double star
notations this shouldn't be new for
anyone just Python syntactic sugar but
when I wrap my function I don't really
care how the allister's and the proximal
implementable function I want just to
pass the argument step on so how can
this be done introducing the inspect
model so the inspect month model gives
me an option to extract the signature
out and to bind my own arguments
regardless of how they're being
represented after binding the arguments
the return value is a basically a
dictionary and I can pass them on to my
function as a dictionary so this is how
my decorator looks now using the
inspection model and I pass it on to the
default format function that every cell
every string head now I can call my
function with as we've seen earlier in
scroll up a bit add up the idea drop
okay like this so the calibrated with
the argument of Inc replaces that and by
the found former function nothing on my
part
just getting the arguments and
forwarding to this format function very
easy to use very simple the code is
attached in the github at the end of the
lecture okay what we got there is this
okay so another thing that the inspector
gives us is an ability to read the
function code now you might want to ask
yourself why would I want to do this so
a really cool trick I found out we say
how many of you are familiar with the
parameter model right good walk so the
parameter model is basically an SSH
client written in Python what these
decorator does basically I erect the
function open the terminal types in the
terminal the code of the function H
preps and returns the result back so
let's see how that works so instance
this is an instance of an ssh client I
call it my server these are my
credentials very secret and I have you a
local call this local function returns
the current walking deal very simple off
dot get caring walking deal if a rep
this function with at my server it runs
at my server you can see that the return
value will be different here
it's my local drive my rocket path on my
Mac machine and this is the best on the
remote area okay so we'll stop here
because of time limitations and I'll
take questions
option invisible and they hope they're
okay so the question was is the
decorator just going the same
personality on the remote road and the
answer is yes with the short Asterix it
basically typed the code on the remote
server so if you're missing packages or
anything else then it might break that
and the quotations and all the time
right okay okay so the question is
either the same as the piping tie - dot
C on the remote hold and pretty much
there's a little bit of proof of
pickling down the way to support pandas
and other features that's pretty much
yeah okay time out
[Applause]